in this lesson we're going to talk about
solving radical equations so definitely
this is something you want to know for
the new revised s80 we're going to go
through two examples go ahead and pause
the video city new design your own and
we'll talk about the concepts involved
with solving radical equations so the
first example it says the square root of
n plus 5 plus y equals nine if M is a
constant meaning just like a number
right and y equals two what is the value
of M okay so go ahead and pause the
video so you can do this one on your own
and we'll do it together so the first
thing that I would do is I would put two
in place of Y like that so we have the
square root of n plus five plus two
equals nine now at this point if you
want you know you can go to the answers
and take those values and just
substitute them in and see if it makes
you equation true so for example if I
put 0 in here that's going to be 0 plus
5 the square root of 5 plus 2 does that
equal 9 know so I know that's not the
correct answer so you can go ahead and
do that back substitution that's
definitely a way to do it the other way
to do it is just to work from the
outside in towards this variable M right
so to do that to work from the outside
in towards am i'm going to subtract two
first okay to get the square root by
itself m plus 5 right then I want to do
the opposite of square rooting okay or
the inverse of square rooting which is
to square both sides okay so now that
brings us to 49 and the square and the
square root here cancels that gives us n
plus 5 and then I just want to get em by
itself so i'm going to subtract five
from both sides so M equals 44 and we've
got it so that's the best answer there
now the thing I want to warn you about
radical equations is that sometimes you
get an answer that's called extraneous
meaning it just gives you a false answer
it doesn't actually work so just to be
on the safe side what you want to do is
quickly take that number put it back
into the original equation and make sure
that makes it true sometimes you might
get two answers and one answer works and
the other one doesn't or they both don't
work and there's no solution or it could
be you know that there's two answers so
we put 44 back in you can see that's
going to be 14
nine square root of 49 is 7 plus 2 is 9
it checks out so we know that 44 is
correct okay let's go to example number
to see if you can solve this one on your
own go ahead and pause the video and
then we'll do it together so square root
of x plus 3 plus x equals 2x plus 1
you're trying to find out what X is now
go ahead and do that one and we'll go
through it together so again what you
can do you know is you can always use
that back substitution technique you
know just taking these values putting
them in making sure that they make the
equation true so let's go ahead and do
that on this one so we put 0 in we get
square root of three plus zero equals 2
times 0 which is 0 plus 1 the square
root of three equal one no so we know a
is not it we go to be put negative 2 in
we get native two plus three witches 1
square root of 1 is 10 k plus one equals
two times one which is two plus one does
to equal three no so we know it's not be
if we go to letter C put white and one
plus three is four square root of four
is two plus one equals two times one
which is two plus one is three so we
could say three equals three that were
so could be this one right but let's
double-check the last one negative two
and one well we know that negative 2
wasn't a solution so it must just be
letter C now the other way to do this
problem i just want to show you if you
remember from your algebra 2 class is
you want to get this radical by itself
so you have square root of x plus 3 i'm
going to subtract x to the other side
which is just going to give you one x
now okay and then what we're going to do
is we're going to square both sides of
the equation but because this is a
binomial two terms you want to foil it
and that's going to give you x squared
plus 2x plus 1 now remember you can
write this as x plus 1 times another X
plus 1 and then do the distributive
property twice or the foil to hear the
square of the square root cancel each
other out and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get everything on one
side of the equation by subtracting
access subtracting 3 that gives you 0
equals x squared plus X minus 2 and then
what you can do is you can factor this
okay and then set each factor each group
equal to 0 so if I do that you can see X
plus 2 equals 0 that means X is negative
2 and X minus 1 equals 0 that
XD positive one so you might be tempted
to think it's letter D if you do it this
way right the only thing is is that
again like I said on example number one
is that you want to double check these
answers by putting them back in and if
you put back in negative two you're
going to see that it doesn't make ants
you know the equation true the left side
will not equal the right side so
definitely make sure you check those
answers they could trick you in that
manner but again you can use the back
substitution technique that works as
well go over this lesson if you need to
otherwise i'll see you in the next
lesson